du trocadéro à paris ils étaient
plusieurs milliers hier à avoir répondu
à l'appel de syndicats de journalistes
de sociétés de rédacteurs ou encore
d'associations défendant les droits de
l'homme dans le viseur le projet de loi
dit de sécurité globale et plus
particulièrement son article 24 ce qui
se joue c'est tout simplement l'état de
droit en france c'est à dire la liberté
d'informer la liberté de filmer dans les
rues la liberté de rapporter en témoin
ce qu'on voit tout simplement
or l'article 24 modifier ou pas ne
changera rien l'intention est de museler
la presse
dans aucun pays démocratique on doit
lever le doigt pour demander si on doit
travailler comme journaliste
donc c'est une imbécillité grave
un article qui prévoit de punir d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amendé le fait de diffuser des images
non floutées d'un membre des forces de
l'ordre
une proposition dangereuse pour de
nombreuses personnes présentes sur place
en ce qui concerne la violence policière
mais on a déjà vu pas mal de choses en
ce qui concerne les chez les jaunes
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est temps que
le peuple français se réveille et je
suis venue manifester c'est parce que on
peut plus rester derrière son écran sur
les réseaux sociaux un moment il faut
agir
je pense que le peuple de reprendre son
pouvoir est finalement avec cette loi la
sphère benalla n'aurait pas existé
puisqu'il n'aurait pas eu les images et
voilà c'est défendre votre métier
défendre ana
un métier aussi qui me tient à coeur
défendre une liberté fondamentale parce
que c'est à nous même si nous sommes
mobilisés tout le monde les jeunes
doivent être là parce que c'est la
société dans laquelle on va grandir et
faucons défendre nos valeurs de liberté
un rassemblement qui s'est déroulé dans
le calme jusqu'aux environs de 17h et
l'appel des organisateurs à la
dispersion de la manifestation
quelques minutes plus tard des
échauffourées éclaté entre manifestants
et forces de l'ordre ces dernières ont
alors fait usage de canons à eau et de
gaz lacrymogènes finalement les
policiers ont chargé les centaines de
protestataires
toujours présent sur place des
journalistes ont également été pris pour
cible comme sur ce coup de pied adressé
à un confrère ou encore lors de cette
scène où une journaliste de rtl france a
été empêché de filmer des policiers
circulez cdo
c'est vous ce que les peindre et 30
secondes vous êtes à terme et c'est
finalement vers 20 heures après deux
dernières invectives que les derniers
manifestants ont définitivement quitté
les lieux devant un parvis des droits de
l'homme
cerné par les forces de sécurité